jornada diplomacia por la guerra en
Ucrania chef recibió al ex
vicepresidente de Estados Unidos y ahora
precandidato por el partido republicano
Mike pence quien argumentó la necesidad
de seguir proporcionando ayuda militar a
Ucrania
dejará claro a Rusia a China y a
cualquier otra noción del mundo que
pretenda redibujar las líneas
internacionales por la fuerza que el
mundo libre no lo tolerará el mundo
libre permanecerá Unido por la libertad
la activista climática greta thunberg
también llegó a la capital ucraniana con
un claro objetivo Mostrar el daño
medioambiental que ha causado la guerra
el ecocidio y la destrucción del medio
ambiente son una forma de guerra como lo
saben muy bien los ucranianos en este
momento al igual que Rusia y es por eso
que están atacando deliberadamente el
medio ambiente
más al este Moscú también fue centro de
diálogos en los que la religión fue
protagonista el enviado del Papa para la
paz en Ucrania Mateo supi se reunió con
el patriarca de la iglesia ortodoxa rusa
kiril manifestó que sus iglesias
deberían trabajar juntas para promover
la paz y la justicia
es muy importante que todas las partes
interesadas en preservar la paz y la
justicia se unan para evitar que la
situación se deteriore
la iglesia es solo uno de los
interesados en mediar en el conflicto
recientemente varias naciones de América
Latina y África también han presentado
sus iniciativas de paz unas que por el
momento no han tenido